>> Greg: IF HE ISN'T THERE, HE
CAN'T SMELL YOUR HAIR.
[LAUGHTER]
IT MUST -- MUST BE TIME TO SET
OUR CLOCKS BACK OR CHANGE THE
WATER FILTER BECAUSE SLEEPY JOE
BIDEN IS ADDRESSING THE PRESS
AGAIN.
YOU'VE NOTICED PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS HAD ONE NEWS CONFERENCE IN
83 DAYS.
TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE, 83
MAY FLY LIFE SPANS.
[LAUGHTER]
ALSO, HE BARELY TWEETS.
NOT EVEN HIS OLD TIMY INSULTS
FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL WHEN HE
CALLED PEOPLE DOG FACED PONY
SOLDIERS OR LILLY LIVERED FLOP
DOODLES AND OTHER SICK BURNS
FROM THE CIVIL WAR ERA.
SO DIFFERENT FROM THE JOE WE
USED TO KNOW.
THE ELECTRIFYING SPEAKER THAT
PLAGIARIZED FROM THE BEST.
THESE DAYS WAITING FOR THE MAN
THAT COULD BARELY STAND UP FROM
HIS OWN SEAT.
AND HE HASN'T DONE INTERVIEWS.
HE MAKES SPEECHES BUT USUALLY ON
THE TELEPROMPTER.
POLITCO SAYS THAT IS THE
STRATEGY.
IT'S ODDLY SUSPICIOUS THAT
BIDEN'S TEAM OPENLY ADMITS IT'S
BETTER IF HE DOESN'T TALK.
WHEN THEY'RE NOT TAKING TURNS
HIDING HIS CAR KEYS, THE WHITE
HOUSE COMMUNICATIONS TEAM IS
RELYING ON CABINET SECRETARIES
TO TALK POLICY INLESS TO IT'S A
WORLD LEADER.
KAMALA ANSWERS THOSE.
HE ANSWERS THE TOUGH QUESTIONS
EARLY ON A SUNDAY MORNING WHILE
HE DOES COCOA AND DOES THE
JUMBLE WHICH ODDSLY MAKES SENSE
IN THE ORIGINAL FORM.
THEN HE CALLS IT A NIGHT WHEN
THE REST OF US ARE CALLING IT
3:00 P.M.
FEELS WEIRD TO HAVE A PRESIDENT
THAT DOESN'T ENGAGE WITH THE
PRESS.
AFTER FOUR YEARS OF THIS.
>> I TOLD THEM I HAVE TO COME
OVER AND SEE THE FAKE NEWS.
LET'S GO.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO AMERICANS
THAT ARE WATCHING YOU THAT ARE
SCARED?
>> I'D SAY THAT YOU'RE A
TERRIBLE REPORTER.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, MY SECOND --
>> GO AHEAD.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
PLEASE.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
BETWEEN YOU PEOPLE, DON'T ASK --
DON'T TALK TO ME THAT WAY.
YOU'RE A LIGHTWEIGHT.
I'M THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
DON'T EVER TALK TO THE PRESIDENT
THAT WAY.
>> Greg: IT NEVER GETS OLD.
MAYBE JOE BIDEN SAW HOW THE
PRESS TREATED TRUMP AND THOUGHT
I DON'T WANT TO TALK TO THEM
EITHER, RIGHT, JOE?
>> I DON'T NEED TO TALK TO THE
PRESS ALL DAY.
I'M A GOOD LISTENER.
TALK TO JILL.
SHE KNOWS.
I KEEP WHAT'S GOING ON.
I HAVE THE PHONOGRAPH ON, THE
RECORD PLAYER.
ANYTHING ELSE, I LOVE IT TO
GEORGE PATAKI.
HE'S GOOD.
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK BEFORE THAT
CUOMO GUY.
HAD A GOOD RUN.
I TOLD HIM DON'T SQUEEZE THE
CHARMIN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: LARA, DO YOU MISS IT?
WHEN YOU WERE WATCHING -- WHEN
YOU WATCH THE BEFORE AND AFTER,
IT'S STARK.
>> HOW BORING IS EVERYTHING NOW.
WE KNEW THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
WHETHER YOU LOVED PRESIDENT
TRUMP OR YOU HATED HIM, HE WAS
THE MOST TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT
IN A LONG TIME THAT AMERICA HAS
SEEN.
YOU SAW HIM.
HE USED TO LOVE TO WALK OUT
THERE.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
THE FAKE NEWS.
EVERYBODY LOVED THAT.
NOW WE GET NOTHING FROM JOE
BIDEN.
I MEAN, HE CAN BARELY GET
THROUGH THESE TELEPROMPTER
SPEECHES.
I WOULDN'T CALL IT A PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT HE'S HAD.
HOW BORING.
IT'S SAD.
>> Greg: KAT, WHAT IT REMIND ME
OF, TRUMP WAS LIKE THE FIRST GUY
TALKING TO CNN.
THAT'S WHY EVERYBODY LIKED IT.
HE DID IT IN THE PRESS.
HE WOULD JUST GO I'M TIRED OF
THIS [BLEEP].
HE WOULD START SWEARING.
NOT SWEARING.
BUT THAT'S WHAT WE NEEDED.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND AND I
HAVE -- THE COMMON NARRATIVE OF
PEOPLE IS I'M NOT WORRIED
ANYMORE NOW THAT BIDEN IS THE
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T HAVE TO -- I'M NOT
HEARING ANYTHING CRAZY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HAVING THAT
MINDSET THAT IF YOU DON'T KNOW
OR SEE SOMETHING THAT NOTHING
BAD COULD BE HAPPENING.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> I PREFER BAD OR GOOD.
THE MORE THAT WE KNOW ALLOW ME
TO AT LEAST KNOW WHAT TO BE
UPSET ABOUT.
OTHERWISE I'M BLANKET UPSET AT
EVERYTHING.
>> Greg: BIDEN IS LIKE A PUG'S
FART.
SILENT BUT DEADLY.
I MEAN, LOOK, HE'S LIKE A --
>> I'M NOT FOLLOWING YOU.
GIVE IT TO ME ONE MORE TIME.
>> YOU CAN BORROW MY FRENCH
BULLDOG.
>> Greg: BULLDOGS EXPLODE.
BUT MY POINT IS THIS.
WE'VE BEEN TRAINED TO THINK THAT
JOE BIDEN IS THIS KINDLY, OLD
GENTLEMAN.
HE'S A VESSEL FOR THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE POLITICS.
THEY'RE SLIDING RIGHT THROUGH.
>> BY THE WAY, HE'S NEVER THAT
KIND.
HE'S BEEN AT THIS GAME A LONG
TIME.
TALK TO CLARENCE THOMAS.
HE'S RUTHLESS.
PEOPLE SAID WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE WAS CRAZY.
THAT WAS THE MOST HONEST MOMENT
WE'VE HAD IN POLITICS IN A LONG
TIME, THIS IS CRAZY.
WE GET PRESIDENT THAT GETS
HANDED CARDS.
YOU'RE DOING A PRETTY GOOD JOB
WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
HE'S HAVING TROUBLE OVER THERE
TRYING TO READ WHAT THIS IS, I'M
SUPPOSED TO SPEAK NOW.
I HAVE TO SAY THIS.
I HAVE COMPASSION FOR HIS
PERFORMANCE BECAUSE I'M LIKE LET
HIM GO HOME.
LET HIM TAKE A NAP.
THAT'S ENOUGH.
WE GET IT.
YOU KNOW, SEND THE STAFF OUT
THERE TO MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
IT'S BETTER.
>> Greg: WHEN I'M THAT AGE, I'M
IN HOME WATCHING FORENSIC
FILES --
>> I'LL BE DEAD.
>> Greg: YOU WILL.
TYRUS, I DON'T THINK THAT
BIDEN'S STRATEGY IS THAT BAD.
IT'S WHAT MY WIFE DOES WHEN SHE
HAS FRIENDS OVER.
SHE ALWAYS MAKES -- TELLS ME TO
GO SOMEWHERE AND STAY AWAY.
NEVER TELLS ME WHY.
SHE SAYS --
>> AFTER THE SHOW I'LL EXPLAIN
TO YOU WHY.
I REALLY FEEL THAT THERE IS NOT
BIDEN'S PLAN.
I FEEL LIKE HE'S BEING HELD
HOSTAGE.
BECAUSE HE'S PROBABLY THINKING
IF I'M NOT OUT MIXING IT UP AND
TALKING AND GETTING MY POINT
ACROSS AND MY AGENDA, HOW AM I
GOING TO GET RE-ELECTED?
HIS TEAM IS LIKE -- OH.
NO ONE HAS TOLD HIM YET.
YOU KNOW, LET ME -- I GOT THIS,
GUYS.
YOU KNOW I'M A TALKER.
I CAN DO -- STICK TO THE SCRIPT,
SIR.
>> CAN I TAKE QUESTIONS?
>> AND THEY SHOW HIM A PICTURE
OF THE SHEPHERD.
I'VE SEEN THIS A MILLION TIMES.
LEAKING ON STORIES ABOUT THE
SHEPHERD, THE SHEPHERD HAS TO GO
TO SCHOOL NOW.
THAT'S THE HOSTAGE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WRAP HIM UP
WITH.
DO WHAT WE SAY AND THE DOG
DOESN'T GET IT.
>> Greg: HAD A SIMILAR
EXPERIENCE WITH A GERMAN
SHEPHERD.
>> OKAY.
>> Greg: NOT THE DO